I know it brought you back you brought
me back no one else just us did he do it
to watch us freeze to death
you
hey everybody so you requested a video
about the multiple endings that season 8
is supposed to have and the other cool
thing is because they just announced the
season 7 DVD is dropping later this year
that's what the weekly giveaway will be
for now so all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video I'll name a new winner at
the end of this - and when people
started messaging me about this I
actually thought it was false because
that sounds ridiculous HBO has a lot of
money but it takes millions of dollars
in weeks upon weeks of time to film
scenes that you might not ever intend on
airing so we just sounded completely
ridiculous but then I saw an article on
Entertainment Weekly which is supposed
to be a legitimate website that HBO uses
as a sort of mouthpiece I'll explain how
that works like they basically serve as
a publication for HBO to put out news
that they want to put out regardless of
how true it is so this is what it reads
in Entertainment Weekly it says this is
Casey boys who's the President of
Programming at HBO so he's sort of like
the Overlord that decides on what's
happening with new seasons what's gonna
happen with the prequel series that
they're developing so he's sort of like
the big boss that makes the biggest
decisions so he says I know in Game of
Thrones the ending they're going to
shoot multiple versions so that nobody
really knows what happens you have to do
that on a long show because when you're
shooting something people know so
they're going to shoot multiple versions
so that there's no real definitive
answer until the end so we can humor HBO
for a little bit but I think honestly if
they're gonna actually do fake endings
take the time to shoot it spend the
extra millions of dollars that's fine
that's their money to spend as long as
they end up releasing those as bonus
content like they'll air the straight-up
version and then after the fact they
could say okay you know here's all those
extra versions just for fun so I think
most people took them at face value but
what's actually probably going to happen
is that they'll just circulate a lot of
fake scripts without actually shooting
some of these scenes there will probably
be a couple moments within scenes that
they film they'll just leave the cameras
running until the actors to do something
on the fly like they'll ad-lib some
scenes
[Music]
but if you remember earlier this year
when kid Harrington said they film
multiple versions of scenes to try and
throw people off that we're leaking
stuff from this set I can't tell you
anything all right all I can tell you is
that what you might have seen on the
internet anyone who follows it is that
might not be true it might be true but
it also might be true and you might be
just saying that to throw us off yeah
yeah yeah how many fake scenes were you
personally involved in 3 3 3 fake scenes
3 fake scenes how many hours of those
fake scenes take to shoot about 5 hours
each
what were those fake scenes that he was
talking about there was actually one
scene on the beachfront where he went up
and kissed a giant styrofoam dragon head
in the thing is is that most people
identify this as false because the
dragons on set are really just tennis
balls they're all completely CG so
they'll hold a tennis ball up when
they're interacting with dragons so like
when Johnson was touching the dragon
here he's just reaching out in front of
green screen there's no physical dragon
prop so most people identified this as
false that is what he was talking about
he wasn't talking about like an extra
week of filming to do a bunch of fake
stuff that didn't end up happening it
was just a couple moments on the beach
while they were getting ready to film
another scene so 100% I totally think
they'll do a lot more of that they'll
just leave the cameras running and
they'll just put stuff in scenes that
aren't gonna be in the final versions so
it's just a lot easier to accomplish
what you would call fake scenes when
everybody's in the same place it would
have been a lot harder a couple seasons
ago when you had people in a bunch of
different countries at the same time
when it comes to the really critical
stuff like the actual big final moments
a lot of that is gonna be shot indoors
on a green screen set like even during
episode 6 when you saw the behind the
scenes you see a lot of this is
green-screen they shot a little bit of
it when they're on that frozen lake but
most of that big battle is all
special-effects with them getting a
bunch of paper blown in their face to
simulate all that snow so a lot of the
big battles with the night king it's
gonna be the same deal there'll be
moments where they're outside filming in
open air but most of the big action will
be done in a computer when they do that
it's a lot easier to control the set so
there's no drone that could fly over and
see what they're doing but I think what
comes to leaking stuff from inside the
crew like people who get their hands on
scripts I think they'll just circulate a
lot of fake scripts so you'll hear a lot
of fake spoilers
they've already been a lot of season 8
script leaks quote-unquote that had been
verified as fake from people inside Game
of Thrones like nope that is completely
false so if you've heard somebody talk
about Game of Thrones spoilers in the
last couple of weeks since the season
ended they're probably fake spoilers but
even though I'm intending on making a
longer death predictions video list
let's actually talk about real endings
so a lot of you were surprised when I
suggested the idea of Jon Snow dying but
I think you know maybe people just
misunderstood what I was talking about
he has a very specific purpose in Game
of Thrones or at least we think that he
has a specific purpose and that is
defeating the night king no matter what
happens to everyone else I do think that
he will be successful in that mission
it's just a question of what happens
after that or in the process of that
like if he defeats the night king but
dies in the process because one of the
running jokes the last couple of seasons
is that Jon Snow is doing everything he
can to try and die now in reality it's
just the way they filmed things in the
surprises that they try to build into
episodes like Battle of the bastards
when he rushes the field to try and save
Rickon he's rushing to his death but
it's not because he wants to die he's
actually trying to save Rickon but when
you stack that with moments like this
where everybody's escaping and he's like
no no no I'm gonna sacrifice myself so
that you can all get away while he's
killing the rest of those whites it
really does seem like he's trying to
sacrifice himself for everybody so
there's just a history of evidence where
he throws himself into situations like
that so that'll continue in season 8 I
think he'll be successful in defeating
the night king with Daenerys and
everyone else at the same time it won't
be a singular effort but in the legit
version of the ending I don't think that
he's going to wind up on the throne but
remember if it's true that HBO is gonna
do those fake endings you could totally
get a copy of The Return of the King
ending where everybody has this big
wedding where he gets married to
Daenerys everybody's there jamie gets
married to Brienne you have tormented to
a Lascar Stark everybody's happy they
live to see their children grow old you
see the slow montage Arya gets married
to Gendry becomes a lady of a castle in
direct
faience of what you know that her
character does not want to do that's how
you know it's a fake ending if she does
the thing she said she would never do we
can call that the soap opera ending the
other alternate ending that I'm really
hoping they do if they actually do fake
endings is the everybody dies ending in
the night King winds up on the Iron
Throne like you get this Daenerys vision
but then you get the fake moment of him
going full-blown Lich King and sitting
on a frozen throne so you can already
tell how ridiculous some of those
endings sound the idea of the
bittersweet ending is the idea that the
characters that you loved accomplished
their goals but died in the process so I
still think that a lot of those big main
characters are gonna die not everybody
but most of them so what will happen is
is I will do my death predictions video
next that should post on Friday or
Saturday but just in the name of fun
post all your favorite fake Game of
Thrones endings in the comments below
like what is the most fanfiction II
ridiculous ending that you think they
could possibly do to try and throw
people off with the real endings going
to be and I know a lot of you have also
asked about the prequel series we've
learned a little bit more about that I
even have an audio clip of the HBO
executives talking about what's going on
with that so probably some time next
week I'll do a prequel video they still
haven't settled on what it's going to be
but they have set a lot of interesting
new things about that and George are
Martin on top of that so congratulations
to the latest DVD giveaway winner Joshua
burns please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details I'll name a new winner
the next time I post Game of Thrones so
while you wait for everything click here
to learn more about the golden company
and click here to learn more about Aegon
Targaryen thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight